[Music]
you kind of good-looking yeah
you're both Oh what if you cause a wolf
no need to look here here thing Sharna
Burgess and Bonner Bolton's chemistry on
Dancing with the Stars is undeniable and
after this slightly awkward hand slip
moment on the season premiere on a viral
appointment it's kind of viral now it's
oh yeah yeah yeah listen he's going yeah
it's getting picked up but that's all
right intentional yeah
no clearly are you but you handled it
very well oh well fans cannot stop
wondering is there a real romance going
on et spoke with Sharna herself she
tells us quote we're not together
we obviously have great chemistry we
love working together and Bonner is an
incredibly good-looking guy I want to
keep supporting him and working hard
every week in the competition now a
source has told us that Bonner does seem
to be attracted to Sharna there's
definitely a spark there but the source
ads whether anything will happen time
will tell
Sharna is a total professional and
focused on the show just weeks ago the
pros sat down with ET and talked about
her love life she's been single for
about a year what kind of guy deserves
Shauna do you know what you're looking
for in a guy I love a strong guy that is
in a confident in his own right I get
through living idents with men for a
living and I'm in the public eye for a
living and it takes a strong man to be
able to to understand that and and to
love that about me
[Music]
you